はい、皆さん、前回のパートはですね、AIエージェントの骨組みまでは作成をしましたが、まだ頭脳がない状態だったかと思います。
このパートはですね、AIエージェントが考える力、いわゆる頭脳を持つために、外部のLLM、AIですね、と接続をしていきたいと思います。
その接続に必要不可欠なのが、クレデンシャル、認証情報というものになりますので、この認証情報について実際に学んでいきたいと思います。
実際にですね、このAIエージェントの考える力、頭脳ですね、を接続させるために必要なのが、この認証情報なんですが、
これはですねこの n8n 自身が gmail だったりスラック また今回追加している llm と呼ばれるような考える力、AIですね
とつなげるために必要なパスワード
であったり、あるいはですね、認証に必要な認証情報ですね。こういったようなものです。
今回はですね、実際にAIの頭脳をつなげていくんですが、まあ様々チャットGPTであったり、クロード、ジェミニなど様々なLLMがございますが、これを一つの認証情報で手軽に利用することができる
オープンルーターというサービスを使ってですね、このクレデンシャルの設定というのをしていきたいとおもいます。
今回はオープンルーターを使用していきますが、ChatGPTであったり、Gemini、これらの設定方法としては同様となりますので、一つ参考にしていただけたらなというふうに思います。
ということで実際にオープンルーターのページに移っていきたいと思いますので、こちらがオープンルーターのサイトとなります。
画面にある通り様々なAIのモデルというのが一つのオープンルーターという認証情報で接続ができたりしますので、非常に便利なサービスですので、皆さんもぜひご利用いただけたらと思います。
またですね、一つ注意点としましては、実際に今回つなげていくLLM、AIの頭脳と言われるような考える力を使うためにはコストというのがかかるんですね。
イメージとしては電気代のようなものです。実際に自動化のワークフローを動かしていくにあたっての電気代のようなものになるんですけども、実際のコストといっても、一般的には1回の実行で1円かかるかかんないか、本当にその程度になりますが、ゼロではないということだけご注意いただけたらと思います。
実際のこの金額については、トークンという単位で計算することができまして、ざっくり言うとですね、文字数に対するトークンなので、1文字1トークンだと思っていただけたらと思います。
ですので、たくさん対話をしたりだとか、実行したり、処理が多ければ多いほどそれだけ料金がかかると、そういったシンプルな仕組みになっておりますので、こちらコスト面も皆様押さえていただけたらなというふうに思います。
ということで、実際にこのオープンルーターの認証情報を取得していきたいと思いますので、まずはですね、こちら画面右上に記載があるサインアップと書いてあるところからアカウントの作成をしていきたいと思います。
こちらサインアップをクリックしますと、Googleアカウント、Gmailアカウントであったりですとか、アドレスまたパスワード等で簡単にアカウント作成ができますので、こちらでまず皆様ですね、アカウントサービスをしていただけたらなというふうに思います。
実際にアカウントの作成が完了してログインができましたら、このような画面、右上にメニュー欄みたいなのが出たかと思います。
ログインしましたら、こちらメニュー欄の方の上から2番目、キーズと言われるようなところをクリックしていただければと思います。
そうしますと、このようにAPIキーという画面が出てくるんですけれども、実際にn8nと接続する認知症情報としては、このAPIキーと言われるパスワードのようなものが必要なんですね。
ですので、この API キーというのをまずは特性をしていきますので、こちら紫のCreate API キーと呼ばれる、こちらから進めていこうかと思います。
そうしますと、このような画面が出てきますが、まず一番上、この発行する API キーの名前というのにつけることができます。
今回はわかりやすくですね、n8nデモという風な名前にしていこうかなと思います。
そして2番目ですね、2番目としてはこちらはクレジットリミット、いわゆる上限ですね、どれぐらいAPIを使用させるか、使用していいかという上限を設けることができるので、こちらも任意で設定することができます。
本日は設定をせず、このまま進めていこうと思いますので、こちらでCreateというふうにキーを作成していきます。
そうしますと、このようにYour New Keyと新しくキーが発行されました、このような画面に移ります。
こちらが先ほどから言っているAPIと言われるような、いわば連携に必要なパスワードのようなものなんですね。
こちらは、他の人に絶対に教えないでください。
皆様のクレジットカードの情報と同じくらい機密性が高くて、非常に重要なパスワードとなりますので、絶対に教えないように押さえていただけたらと思います。
私もこの後すぐ削除しますので、ご注意ください。
こちらのキーが発行できましたら、右側のこちらからコピー、忘れないようにメモであったりとか、他のツールにペーストして覚えておくようにしてください。
では、そうしましたらですね、バッテン印を押して、追加されますので、今回の発行したAPIキーを使って、n8n AIエージェントの方につなげていきたいと思います。
そうしましたら、こちらの画面に戻っていただいて、早速ですね、このAIで考える力というのを与えていきたいと思いますので、こちら、AIエージェントと書いてあるノードの左側にぶら下がっているチャットモデル、こちらのプラスボタンを押していただければと思います。
そうしますと、このようにですね、チャットモデル、いわゆるAIの頭脳というのが、たくさんいろんな種類がつなげられますが、今回は発行したこのオープンルーターチャットモデル、こちらを選択していきたいと思います。
そうしますと、私はちょっと入ってしまっているんですが、皆さんは何も入っていない状態かと思います。
先ほど取得した認証情報を使って接続を行っていきますので、こちら、Create New Credential というボタンを押していただいて、接続を行っていきます。
こちらですね、先ほど発行したこの API キーと書いてあるところにペーストをしていただいて、セーブと。
実際に認証が完了しますと、このように緑色の表示がされますので、これで連携OKという形になります。
これで連携OKですね。
ただですね、連携自体はできたんですが、1点注意点がございました。
実はこのOpenRouterというサービスなんですが、基本的な仕様としましては、デポジット製のサービスとなるんですね。
イメージとしてはSuicaだったりとかPathmoと同様にですね、あらかじめオープンルーター側にクレジットというのをチャージしていく必要があって
事前にチャージされていたクレジットの中から使用するごとに減っていくといったサービスになるので、今回ねオープンルーターをそのまま使われる方はクレジットのチャージっていうのが必要ですし
また、n8nからもですね、実はプレゼントがあって、ちょっといったんオープンルーター切りますが、実際にこのオープンAIのチャットモデルですと、最初n8nから100クレジット分無料でプレゼントがn8nから頂けるので、まず無料枠を使っていきたいよという方は、こちらオープンAIのチャットモデルを追加頂いて、多分この辺り紫色になっている部分があるので、それを押して頂けると無料で100クレジット分無料でプレゼントが頂けます。
今回はオープンルーターを使っていきますが、ぜひ無料枠で試していただけたらと思います。
それでは本題に戻りまして、実際にチャットモデルを追加できましたので、再度セーブを押してちゃんと動いてくれるか、返答してくれるかというのを実行してみたいと思います。
はい、では改めて、こんにちはと、エラーが出ました。こちらですね、失礼しました。これで問題ないかと思います。
はい、このようにですね、進路動いたかと思います。ようやくですね、こんにちは、ご用件は何でしょうか、返答が返ってきました。
これでですね、実際のなんちゃってチャットGPTができてきたかと思います。
また、こちら下のメニュー欄のログと書いてある部分ですが、こちらで実際の動き、実行履歴というのもこちらで確認ができたりだとかしますので、こちらもちゃんとどのように動いているのかななんて確認もしつつ、
あとはつなげたオープンAIだったりとか、オープンルーター、これで消費したトークン数というのもこちらで確認することができますので、どのぐらいかかったかなというのもこちらから見ていただけると良いかなと思います。
ということで、少しずつチャットGPT、なんちゃってチャットGPTはできてきたかなと思うんですが、さらにですね、より便利、またまだまだ欠点がある
なんちゃってチャットGPTですので、次回以降もですね、次のパート以降もまだまだ多くの機能を追加していきますので、皆さんもぜひお楽しみいただけたらなというふうに思います。